[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link joining us today at the round
table of dim lighting is youtuber
filmmaker and really good friend of ours
Joe Penna aka mystery guitar man you
know mystery guitar man we had the
pleasure of and we would have the
pleasure of knowing Joe for many yes we
still know him we can laugh we're still
friends and you know great guy amazingly
talented and it was cool to talk to him
right so in just in case you don't know
about Joe he exploded on the internet
with this popular stop-motion video back
in 2009 guitar impossible guitar as
people are like anywhere but this guitar
like you say guitar guitar impossible
and it's got currently over 15 million
views this kicked off a series of
stop-motion videos where Joe would play
an instrument almost anything at all
really soda cans balloons kazoos and he
would make a stop-motion music video out
of it these videos are literally frame
by frame one note at the time added
together to create a song here's a clip
of him playing Mozart with root beer
bottles via the magic of editing
[Music]
you really gotta watch the videos to
fully appreciate them and then when you
do watch them there's a level of
engagement that I it kind of comes in
waves of that's cool well he did this to
make that and then there's like layers
of understanding that lead to layers of
appreciation of all the stuff Joe does
and one of the interesting thing we
talked about is how that appreciation
that really translated into millions and
millions of views back in Ohio 9 2010
isn't necessarily translating into
millions and millions of views today and
would get Joe's perspective on that yeah
it's an interesting phenomenon I mean
our appreciation of his work translated
into us reaching out to him very early
we talked about this collaborating on
every t-shirt war video we've done what
you've done - yes so all two of them so
from the get-go he was instrumental in
in in that video for us but today you
get to hear and actually for the first
time we got to hear Joe's side of the
story of collaborating you know I mean
we had exchanged emails but we met to
work on t-shirt war and there were a
couple of facets to his experience that
blew my mind
yes specifically a near catastrophic
story involving the footage that we
never knew about this so he drops a bomb
on us oh yes in this ear but it's ok
because this means many years later so
we were able to survive it but he's more
than just a stop-motion madman his
YouTube channel currently with 2.8
million subscribers also features much
of short films that he's directed if you
consider short films to be 40 minutes
long I guess technically they're that
still a short film but he's doing that
kind of thing making very cinematic
short films on his YouTube channel so we
talked to Joe about those films
including where he's going with all that
what that is working towards and what
he's got in store in the future and of
course we also talked about his
backstory which was super fascinating
including
it's the really interesting I'll call it
peculiar I just I'll just call it that
technique that he'd developed to adjust
to life in the u.s. having moved as a
kid from Brazil so like I said we really
enjoyed reconnecting with Joe I know
that you're really gonna enjoy our
conversation with him too but first we
want to remind you that you can download
our new album song biscuits Volume one
one of X X fill in the blank I don't
know how many we're gonna make where
there's one right now 15 songs you can
get that on iTunes or Amazon
remember these are the songs that we
wrote in collaboration with other
creators based on your suggestions
through the Twitter's and the Facebook
sometimes here's a clip from one of our
favorite songs on this album the
10-second rule song featuring nice Peter
[Music]
literally on the trail 15 songs guys so
head over to iTunes and download them
thanks for supporting entertainment and
for rating and leaving a review on
iTunes also available on Amazon
alright and now onto the biscuit first
time I wrote in an electric car I'm
trying to remember all the things
because we go way back way back but the
first time I wrote in like a 100%
electric car was your car oh yeah the
Tesla Roadster do you still have it I
don't I sold it we moved into we started
renting a place because we were saving
up to buy a house okay and we moved into
this place where it was before the law
required people to allow electric cars
to be in the you know hookups basically
so I couldn't charge my car and there
was ever like places to charge and it
was the old Tesla so I couldn't just
charge it up in the public chargers
either so it was taking me like two days
to charge up my car just out of normal
outlets you know so you had a revert
yeah so I had to revert back to my IC II
don't turn a combustion engine you know
well yeah it's sad big isida yeah but
now that you've got a place oh you're
gonna put a charging station and go back
yeah because I have solar panels in my
roof
and I it would be super cheap for me to
go back to electric so yeah I'm gonna
wait until the next day you have you you
have to have a special like converter in
your garage to like properly charge one
if you want to charge it up fast
yeah otherwise it takes like 48 hours
for you to charge
oh really and that's not worth it okay
mm-hmm just out of you know normal
outlets from the wall right it's like
charging up your the battery on your
phone if you had a thousand phones in
your car
but but that you wrote in the car right
after me right right that day not get
the right I don't know if I actually got
this at the YouTube space I think I was
just there when you when you started it
up and that just meant getting into it
and like pressing a button and there was
no indication that the car was on and
then you just backed up and I was like
the future is here I don't hear anything
you
that's right I actually didn't ride in
your car either it's just my memory it
was it was so impactful mm-hmm that I
felt like I was right the first time you
stood next to an electric car what we
came the first time you rode into it
yeah yeah I just remember being struck
with the same thing well I dream Connor
it's all in your memory it's uh yeah
yeah you fabric you fabricated all of
this so you also never had a pilot
license because I remember that too no I
was starting to get my pilot license you
bailed on that too I know I just don't
blame everything on the baby no one at
the pilot license place recognized me so
right started becoming very mystery what
it was aside $15,000 to get a pilot
license here but you've built up some
credits that you can then go back yeah
yeah and I did a lot of similarity stuff
which counts towards your hours but then
once the baby came around my wife was
like no you're not allowed to ride a
motorcycle or or plane oh yeah I used to
have a dream of you can't ride in a
plane anymore little planes little
planes right I had a dream of going up
in a ultralight trike and then you know
my wife gave me the you have children
you have to learn what would happen yeah
in my life I'm like you can take care of
them you're fine I've seen you yeah so
Jonah how old is he no he's nine months
nine months so nine months into
fatherhood you shouldn't know what it
feels like by now I don't sleep anymore
but I wasn't sleeping before and so but
you've already harnessed the power of
exploiting him for the four YouTube
video cute baby up there at the end blog
now it's not I don't I just don't have
to wait around for Joe to start talking
about subscribing now I got I got I got
a good reason you got a reason yes hang
her out right it would be better video
donor I dressed up in a black morph suit
and got like little tiny instruments so
basically found the smallest cello that
there was it was about the same size as
an upright bass for him you know and
found all these tiny little instruments
and then did a video where I'm helping
him play along and it was bad yeah and
his uh that we were talking about that
hit the look on his face is that
having a great time and then I was like
this had to happen over the course of a
few days unless you just have a baby
that has an incredible personality
attitude howdy - we got very she's got a
great personality too but attitude there
people have tried that video with baby
link it would have never happened it
would've been a do it been different for
it's been running for a difference yeah
every like picture of me as like a kid
once I was aware of pictures of me were
being taken like against that like Kmart
backdrop every single one for like other
backgrounds was oh yeah I was like
red-faced in tears like I hate it unless
we're Lando gets Lando refuses to have
his picture taken I know he'd not take
part in any sort of you'd think I was
the paparazzi and he was like John
Travolta no yeah you couldn't do that
video with Lando now but it would be a
great video if you did it but it would
be like people would think it was abuse
yeah just a baby crying so I'm eating
there Jonah that was all like in one
shoot sighs OH
three horses yeah he was there for three
hours he hates getting his clothes
changed so that was annoying about him
so by the end of it he was like I don't
do this anymore
but was Sarah like behind the camera my
ass she was rated camera yeah all the
like for a long time we still have the
audio from the camera it was just Sarah
like a reverse on her this is what it
that's a great behind this I was really
scared you know cuz I'm wearing a black
morphsuit but he was just like laughing
at me and half the time he's just like
looking up at me be like what is going
on behind me like would your face
covered - yeah you know what that would
affect me even a normal child would have
been freaked out so you've got something
special on your hands
do you have an extraordinary boy and of
course you name - Jonah so that you
could then gift the channel to your JP
channel that's the only reason yes
Alyssa that again oh yeah it was we
didn't realize this until later but it
was it's half my name half her name we
Brangelina our kid oh you know what and
you didn't even know it we didn't even
know it cuz my name is Jonas uh-huh and
her name is Sarah so join us Sarah Joan
Jonah yeah yeah you put on it that's a
great realization and now on you should
just say that was intentional oh yeah I
was totally in will you know of course
it'll be on this podcast we're gonna
name a Brin Jelena but my wife a little
weird so you're gifting the channel yeah
now so now YouTube comments last JP is
no longer your second Channel right it's
it's his channel and mom's channel is
that really how it's gonna work really
hit moms you know me but you're
basically like putting him to work I
mean like officially I mean we've he's
got a he's got to get to it right yeah
yeah it's expensive having a baby
it's got my cribs he's got to pay for
himself it's for you well let with all
this baby talk let's go back to you
let's do it as a baby me as a baby you
as a baby
we're what you were born born in Brazil
more specific in some Paulo in Brazil
big city and then we moved out to the
suburbs of some pilot a little tiny city
that I recently went back to visit and
you've got siblings I think we met your
sister assist yeah yeah but she's
younger so you were like the first kid
of the first kid of three and the my
little brother is in high school now
okay and that's it that's the third
three you guys uh-huh yeah that's the
three of us so you're in Brazil yeah and
what was your dad doing at the time my
dad was an engineer he he was an
engineer my mom was a schoolteacher and
you know he wanted us to to have a an
education here an American education to
learn English you know he was seeing
that English was an important thing he
spoke enough to get around you know he's
like if if they have an American college
degree they can come back to Brazil and
make like five times as much money and
you know if they speak English that'd be
good for them so we moved here first to
Massachusetts and you were how old I was
11 turning into 12 mm-hm so yeah very
great time to move so what do you
remember about the move what was your
mindset it's cooled it I mean that a big
part of the motive was for you and your
siblings you know how did you feel about
it I I was I was excited about it you
know at first I was like I don't want to
move
I've got my friends here but then you
know I started thinking about my future
and it was the very first time as a kid
because yeah as a kid you don't think
about your future the very first time
that I'm like okay this this makes sense
this will be good in the long run it'll
hurt a little bit right now I'll have to
lose my friends I have to like learn
English you know I knew two words
welcome and balloon and that was it yeah
yeah yeah good at welcoming balloons
I was yeah yeah welcome balloons you
know that's that's where I got it from
so how did you you know what was the
process of learning English like so we
we moved out from that kind of area to
closer to my dad's job which was far
away from any Brazilian community so I
didn't know anybody you know I you know
there was a Spanish kids in school you
know the Puerto Ricans a lot for Ricans
in Massachusetts too but I never fit in
with those kind of people or the
American so I tried to assimilate as
much as possible I started I tried out
for the baseball team and baseball is
anything that isn't like I didn't know
the rules
there were 24 no soccer team do that
that would have been a lot yeah I know
right I never played soccer that's why I
could kick that a Brazil really yeah and
they I was never any good at it no so
you know we try it out there were 24
people I think who tried out for the
baseball team and 22 made it I didn't
play baseball that you remember the
other person I do he was he was really
really large he was like I think over
200 pounds okay for a high school
student right yeah it was it was very
big right yeah so I try to assimilate as
much as possible like I I thought that
being American men being preppy so I
went to like American Eagle and I bought
a bunch of preppy clothes and I put them
on and then I got a couple companies
yeah nice shirt man and then the next
day because I got a couple compliments I
wore the same shirt and then it was like
wait no that's the same shirt you were
in yesterday I was like but I washed it
it was yesterday yeah that's not cool
today you had a big eagle on it
yesterday and it still does today and I
was the youngest kid in school because I
I skip sixth grade so I you know a
double bad for me right in your draw my
life you said that you would go to
in the supermarket and talk malls and go
to the mall and talk to strangers to
random malls I would drive out to like
malls that I would never go back to ever
again because I knew that I know anybody
there we're talking here's 16 by that
time you're a teen yeah yeah okay so
you've been around you'd been in the US
for five six years well yeah still
trying to master this thing right
exactly yeah cuz it made me very shy I'm
not being able to talk to anyone not
being able to have any I was kind of
like the loner kid you know me and like
three other guys in school so like I
haven't been back to any high school
reunions or anything like that cuz I
didn't have friends well what was the
mall technique the mall technique I
would just go back to to any mall that I
would never go back to ever again and
talk to random strangers and come up to
them and shake their hand and say hey
I'm a very shy person and I would like
to talk to you too yes that's that's it
to talk to you that's it this is so
counterintuitive though to to be shy but
to be willing to go to a random mall and
talk to a stranger because that's
something that a lot of normal non shine
on shine people would have a difficult
yeah doing yeah and I figured that that
was like the hardest challenge for me
and I read somewhere that was like if
you if what is it like it was like if
you're afraid of spiders just like buy
yourself a tarantula you know if you're
afraid of of this and that I'm afraid of
talking to people I'm just gonna go and
talk to random strangers and it's
Massachusetts Western Massachusetts a
lot of them weren't very kind right you
know it's like what are you trying to
sell me kid I don't know you're trying
to rob me or something really yeah I got
a lot of that but you know every once in
a while you know I started learning the
little techniques to talk to people so
like when you approach somebody you
don't approach them head-on you don't
say hey I'm here to talk to you you kind
of push them to the side and you ask him
a question that is that has a time of
life you know what time it is or
something like that or like do you know
where I can find out the best buy around
here and then they answer something like
that it's like oh do do you think that
Best Buy or Circuit City is better and
then you start turning enjoys the peace
we know the answer to that yeah
that's by the time oh really because I I
bought this thing over there at Circus
and I thought that it was okay and then
you start getting into a conversation
somebody kind of naturally start getting
into it but you know it's so weird
because you sound like either like a
weird evangelist or a weird like there
would be salesman who doesn't I mean
back in North Carolina one way you go
into the Barnes & Noble and you'd be
like they would they would hang out in
certain places certain types of salesmen
and you'd be like in looking at
magazines or books at Barnes & Noble and
someone will come up start talking to
you and it would rest assured it would
be a Salesman a pitch or something would
be a sales pitch like Avon yes it was
almost it was almost always the Amway
guys because in any way uses well they
also go by another another name but it's
essentially like it's a pyramid scheme
hmm you got some you get people to level
marketing what yeah yeah is not
multi-level marketing and I think that
covers a wide variety of products but
there's always an initial technique that
you're in this conversation and you're
like in this way yeah yeah but for you
it was just because I needed I need to
break through yeah my shyness at first a
lot of people were like worried that I
was gonna sell them something you know
people like that what really what what
do you have to sell to me I'm like I
just wanted to talk to you about the
movies that are good didn't know or did
you give up on it now it helped me
helped a whole lot so you you like
became a master of this oh yeah yeah I
don't knew the techniques like the
approaches the circuitcity banter circus
no yeah I don't think that I would be
married to Sarah today had I not done
this you met her in a mall I met her at
them all and I sidled up to her it gave
me the the social skills to be able to
talk to people you know especially women
because I was very very worried about
talking to women because I was like
they're gonna think that I'm hitting on
them or something use the side product
into the side projection thing that's
right yeah yeah you know I told him like
I'm gonna go to the mall and but I don't
think that they knew that why I was
going to and talk to strangers and talk
to strangers link's do you think they
would have would they have described you
as yeah Joe's working on his you know
his social skills would then would they
have known that that's where you were at
at the time if where they've been really
surprised to know that this is how you
were kind of treating yourself I don't
know I think they were just glad that I
was out of my room because there was
like a whole summer that I didn't leave
and I was just on this this website you
use something YouTube like the entirety
of it I was just there you know it was
even before YouTube actor so I was like
oh i was in the united TI blargh web
sites which was the calculator
programming web sites you know I I have
like 3,000 posts in web sites
I was moderator I wrote a whole
operating system for the ti-83 in
assembly really yeah yeah I was what
does the operating system do it just you
can flash it so that basically it's like
you know if you took out like like the
fire phone the Amazon fire phone is
basically Android that switched around
to be just Amazon stuff so I would like
i coded Mario levels and my Super Mario
Brothers and like a lot of and I started
seeing other kids playing it you know so
it kind of became like my first
experience with viral stuff you know you
made like a Mario game on a ti-83 yeah
yeah yeah mm-hmm and people could
download it from that from that forum
from the website yeah TI calculator like
oh my god I play that game so how did
you yeah because that was the other
thing I wanted to kind of crack open
yeah is you know we know the way that
you've approached your YouTube career
and it's very technical and mechanical
and there's like a methodical yeah
there's an engineering program or sort
of scientific approach so so that's the
way that was kind of coming out
a kid was getting into things like this
like programming their calculator
definitely yeah and I wanted to I mean
if it's yeah I've heard my videos
described that's surgical and it's
interesting because I was in in med
school and I was gonna I was about to
get into med school and I was gonna be a
surgeon hmm so so yeah it's very grad
school so just to connect the dots from
high school yeah you you may went to
pre-med and UMass okay so you moved to
Boston yeah yeah I moved to Boston and
took your ti-83 calculator was hook it
with I took the 89 at that point
actually yeah I I like stuff yeah it's
big stuff yeah there's a lot of a
calculus deficit so for years premed
yeah I mean describe I was in a five
year it was three years for pre-med and
then two years for it to get my masters
so that I could start right away and I
was taking a lot of extra classes for
that so I didn't have much time during
high school during college I mean to be
doing YouTube which is when you know I
got started for me but I still did it
you know I was exhausted and I would
still be like editing videos and I'm
like why am i doing this and I realize
what and why did you choose that there
why did you choose you know become a
surgeon was there like a family
expectation of wow my dad moved us here
so that we could be successful and I
feel obligated to do something that big
a big job yeah you know you hear that
you know doctors and lawyers and like
those kind of things is is what you
should be you know in yeah my I saw how
much my dad my dad sacrificed you know
because he used to be an engineer in
Brazil and then when he got here he
would wake up at 3 o'clock in the
morning deliver newspapers and then go
and work at a pizza place all day you
know while he was looking for a job hmm
it was 2001 mm no mm yeah 2001 it was
right after a recession because I'm at
11 it and things like that you know so
he couldn't find a job anywhere and so
you know it was tough
for a really really long time um when
when we first got here so I was like I
got to do something big you know so I
figured surgeries surgeons surgeons make
a lot of money all right I'll do that
right so that's kind of where the
ambition your ambitious guy to begin
with but the way it was directed
based on that sort of sense of
obligation yeah and what I love I ology
- yeah so and you know you had you know
your dad being an engineer you sounds
like you had that that mindset that
ability you had you had the brains for
this thing I mean your county or you're
you making Mario on it on it on a
calculator
I will small aside here I didn't make a
- xur adventure Merle Haggard game on
tid - no like a text one it was all text
it had no it had a couple of little
graphics when you - you didn't rescue
Merle Haggard from prison because he was
imprisoned at one point and in my
advanced math class the only thing I did
was work on this game the end of the
year it was on like my calculator and
that I like transferred it to links and
it's and I had in college for a long
time t-80 - yeah I had that the
processing power and I had that game on
there and then one of these days was
some day you know the calculator got
lost but it was no Mario I don't know I
can't even begin to imagine we didn't
have we didn't have know about that
website you could have uploaded it and
it could have gone viral probably have
as much as Joe yeah there's a lot of
demand from Merle Haggard at prison use
so the parallel story of you know when
you're going off to college from like a
social standpoint of you kind of dismal
regimen of adapting - yeah you know
interpersonal communication yeah where
were you at that point like going off to
college that had to been a milestone
yeah I was a lot better than I was a
commuter to college so I I didn't have
it still was difficult for me you know
we just didn't have the money for me to
live there you know it was close enough
it was 40 minutes away so you know 40
minutes there for a minutes back but
even in okay so that I mean you're you
created your channel you caught it
mystery guitar man yeah
right off the bat so it's like you
guitar glasses right from the start so
what went into that there's nothing a
pre-med in there there was a Nintendo
pre-med guitar man so thankfully so give
us the story of the start of the channel
and the glasses at the time they
were people who were doing these like
lisanova and little loca and we're doing
like these kind of what's a call them
like characters on YouTube you know and
I was like okay what could be my thing
and I shot my first like little vlog of
me just talking to the camera I think I
didn't even put it up and Mayra so my
camera was broken so I had my glasses on
now I did put that one up yet I have my
glasses on I was like uh you know
glasses mystery you know so I put in
mystery and that was taken of so mystery
man that was taken and looked around
there was a guitar sitting there was
like a mystery guitar that was taking
mystery guitar man that was the only
thing it was like you had to it's one of
those things got a creator username and
then it's yeah I'm gonna do it right now
process of elimination it was four
o'clock in the morning when I said a
minute because that's when I received a
welcome YouTube email I kept everything
writing every single time someone
subscribed to me I can search for that
yeah and then in the net spin it's been
your trademark yeah the sunglasses have
been your trademark yeah yeah I wished
that Oakley would see that but yeah it's
been it kind of became my thing because
I bit a couple video without the glasses
and people like no no you like put the
glasses back on like you you need to to
keep them on for more like a branding
standpoint like we just like that people
are like they didn't like your eyeballs
yeah I feel like I've also weird like
put your glasses back but not are you
are you just being funny are you being
for real now for real like I got those
kind of comments oh you'll get all types
I guess oh yeah and at the time I didn't
have a thicker skin that I have nowadays
you know cuz YouTube back then wasn't as
you know wasn't hidden by anonymity was
kind of like you know everyone was like
oh I love this video but everyone is
super positive and then you know you get
a couple the mean ones and that's how I
can focus on you know even though there
are a hundred like oh this is a great
video there's one that's like I see the
green screen over the top right at one
minute in fish yes right you know that
guy gets you so you so you're telling me
that you happen to be wearing sunglasses
and like a first vlog that you did
mm-hmm but then you decided it wasn't a
thing you just did it yeah it was then
when you when you didn't do it yeah
people were like saying mean things
about your eyeballs yeah
not only that but not only the mean
things but like Oh like your name is
mystery guitar man you should keep the
glasses on the whole time you know and
like so comments like that not only just
mean things but but maybe the mean
comments kind of reinforce okay it's
like well right right because my
comments are the only thing you can
remember really yeah yeah yeah you focus
on the one out of 1000 what it say I
definitely get that so and it ironically
reinforced something that which which
was good brain and invites me because
it's not people like things latch on to
plus it's great for me when I'm at
VidCon if if I want to get to from A to
B from one panel to the other I can just
remove the glasses in and I'm a
real-life Clark Kent now any also I mean
it helps you're able to monitor yourself
constantly but they don't wouldn't no
one know oh yeah oh my god it's so easy
especially when I've done TV shows where
I can just read literally I can just
tape a little thing to the screen and
you know right now I'm looking at you
but I could be looking at him and no one
oh yeah and so then okay how did you
begin to make that transition into
making the kinds of videos that became
your hallmark like where did that idea
yeah yeah I started learning more about
editing you know so I wanted to push
editing at the time you know there were
a couple people doing that cool editing
tricks and After Effects things you know
and I'm I don't want to get into that
you know so I started doing videos with
clones you know you definitely see the
seam in the middle because the camera is
not it's in a lot of focus or whatever
you know and then I said okay what's
wrong with this like what why didn't
this works and I would search it up and
I wouldn't find anything and it was okay
so I would tried three or four different
things literally my vlogs would take
about an hour to shoot even though they
were about 15 seconds 20 seconds long
because I would say a bunch of things
I'd go back to the Edit and I'm like I
didn't work and I would say a bunch of
other things and then go back to the
Edit and then I'd get bored and just go
okay I'll just put that in that's fun
you know and yeah so it kind of became a
style where like I would shave a frame
off of everything and see what that
sounded like
so you start learning like okay on the
esses as soon as you see that's you can
cut on oh you're gonna let that go a
little longer you know you start
learning literally like to the frame
editing for the vlogs and
and you come out with the guitar
impossible yeah yeah it was uh there
were a few stop-motion things before
that right not as fancy like toying with
like parking meters right or things like
that right yeah yeah but then this I
mean that was the big one
dude you know I think this is gonna be a
big one I've told myself that yeah I was
working at an editing house at the time
and I was like stop motion with people
like it's been done here and there's a
guy called Paul versus a Steve or
something like I forget what it's called
like where they're fighting around it's
not motion I was like that's cool but
there's no musical element to it you
know like the I think it'd be cool to do
something big and at the time YouTube
used to handpick videos to go on the
front page or the getting featured was
like a big thing but you guys ever get
featured by the way yeah I think you
guys a couple times right yeah that we
had technically the first feature for us
was called the unibrow song yeah yeah we
wanted to feature Rhett son doing like a
rant about a basketball game Wolfpack
versus Tar Heels but we asked them not
to do it to the future something
defeatist amounts that we were trying to
yeah that was very really important back
in those days
oh yeah it was huge because you know
that's the front page of YouTube YouTube
is is appearing everywhere Dane Cook
talked about it and on SNL and we were
like oh my gosh they in like real this
is real know you already in LA at that
point no still massachusett okay so
you're still in so okay so I want to
make sure that we connect the dots but
yeah yeah you know school and so you're
still in school in schools then and then
when working on this really ambitious
guitar video yeah and that right before
that video I told my dad can I take a
year off of school or six months I said
six months off of school because I want
to try this YouTube thing I'll try this
video thing out No and then I got myself
a job at making horrific amounts of
money
editing for some guy you know off of
Craigslist or something but that gave me
a lot of experience in actually
switching the final cut from Vegas what
would your dad say yeah I thought that
he was gonna be super mad at me but he
was like do it for a year you know and
then you got that job yeah yeah and and
I was he's like if you don't do it you
regret it for the rest of your life you
know so there are things a good life
yeah yeah he said there are things like
that that I regret in my life that I
wish I could have tried my life would
have been different now adays you know
so do it yeah and what were you editing
for the dude that you were getting
overpaid just like he was doing like
thousand dollar music videos and things
like that you know just like kind of
ripping off a lot of artists back then
and I could see you know that it was
they weren't good shooters that he was
using so I would try my best to fix as
much of it in post
as possible you know and to like add a
lot of spice to those videos you know
and then maybe spare time you were you
were hitting YouTube harder I had this
brainchild of an idea right yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna play Mozart yeah yeah so
I do the video and I so that was video
you played each individual note and they
just you would like play it and wait
move play it play the next block the
next string I had a like a giant sheet
music front of me where I'd be like okay
this C sharp is done you know and now
that the D is done and you just kept the
camera rolling cast on mm-hmm virus
video yes V tape mm-hmm 12 really 12 a
12 hours of video because I would play
the same note a couple different
positions a couple different times you
know yeah
and then you had to develop a catalog
even to find every note if you had 12
hours uh now I bet him I bit him
sequentially well that helped yeah yeah
so cutting out all the sound effect
exactly yeah and then you know timing it
out to the song you know so I I did it
at a BPM where it was like so like two
frames is a quarter note four frames is
the math involved a lot of math involved
yeah I was you know I had scripts back
then for it for stuff you know so I I
did it all
I finished the video and I throw in this
little snippet at the end where I'm
singing a flat of the Conchords you know
you know just for fun you know because I
like doing that you know throwing out
something yeah yeah so then I go to
sleep and I put the video up and I'm
exhausted because it's I'm up for so
long in my god
I wake up and it has a hundred and fifty
thousand hits and I'm like a hundred and
fifty thousand people saw this that's
that's how you were sleeping while I was
sleeping that's like a true three people
you know I was I was amazed so like I
had to get to work that day so I get to
work in him my god look a hundred and by
that time was like three hundred in
something I'm like look at this it's
blowing up it'sit's this is gonna work
any and we were walking back from lunch
and he points at a homeless guy he goes
listen man you stop it with this online
crap like you you have to focus on doing
real work music videos your boss Tom
this is my boss Chuck and yeah he goes
you have to do real videos stuff that's
gonna go up on MTV and vh1 because this
is just a waste of time
and I was late you know so I was like
ten minutes late that's why he was
giving me the spiel he's like you're
gonna end up like that guy if you keep
doing the seafood thing and then the guy
goes don't listen to him right now and
he rolls over and there's a laptop he
wasn't my space star though yeah so that
was that was that was when I quit you
know that I that thing and I was like
you know what I'm gonna do it that day
that well no I took a couple extra very
good paying jobs okay but it wasn't it
they but I wanted to quit that day you
saw it counts you quit and then what and
then I I did another video and then
another one another one and then I got
picked to do this Fiesta Movement thing
where they give you a car for six months
and I mean you've done the video with
Toby where it was the - yes you would do
that one before that yeah yeah where
like he uploaded half of a video and
then I below - half of a video you play
him at the same time yeah yeah you hit
play on one and then there's a countdown
and then you hit play on mine and then
you know so like I was playing around
like that and I had recorded a video and
I sent Toby the video and then he it's
Toby you know so he was nuts he was like
jumping all around the screen and he was
like coming after the camera and getting
because it was a guitar duel where it
was timed out where if you play both
videos yeah you guys are playing back a
fourth dueling with each other exactly
yeah but he's so his performance is the
tillers
toby performance and i'm like an idol i
just look like a zombie next to him you
know and i'm like i got it i gotta
rerecord my stuff so I kept the audio
and ivory recorded all my video where
I'm kind of matching his level of
enthusiasm no and people are like oh my
god this is awesome so that kind of
helped me to like kind of be more
animated or animated Toby gave you your
stage presence yeah yeah oh Jesus Toby's
manic what do you call it like state of
being it's funny we just call it Toby
now oh it's just Toby now it's funny
though like when you see you're so like
what were the chances that you were
going to literally see yourself next to
someone and B if I come here it's like
the perfect recipe for innovating and
realizing like okay I'm gonna you know
and so that's like one of your signature
things and the house little I you know I
I took you guys the songs and put it
into my stuff you know and like sounding
songs you know I recorded a country song
that ended up in one of my my videos
that literally I just was singing what
you guys were singing you know the Ford
Fiesta thing was like it this was a
sponsorship yeah yeah yeah it was a free
car free insurance free gas so I did I
was like I will never have the chance to
do this again
so I'm gonna drive all around the
countryside I would tweet out hey I'm in
Philadelphia who's got a room for me and
someone would treat back hey come come
to me and I would follow them they DM me
their address I would show up sometimes
would be creepy how creepy did it get I
got a little creepy one time but it's
alright it was just a misguided person
oh it's okay I was single I mean you're
the one you're the one replying to the
tweets I know I know I know but yeah so
you know I would just drive all over all
the country it took me about a month to
get to LA and I had about 60 bucks left
um you know it was a hundred sixty bucks
like that would me but the plan was to
get to LA to get to a light and to see
if I could find an apartment and I was
hoping to have like eight hundred nine
hundred dollars on me but you know there
was a lot of cities in the middle of the
country that no one respond
so I had to find like a Travelodge or
whatever like that yeah right
so I a friend of mine is in Vegas he's
like hey I've got two rooms in Vegas
friend of mine couldn't show so I've got
an empty room here in Vegas
you want to come to Vegas and like I'm
not a Vegas guy but but I know how to
live in LA now so I go to Vegas and I
play poker until I get $900 yeah and I
see you started with I say 160 once it
was something like I forget exactly how
much I've looked up because I have a
very bad memory but I go back to LA and
I have literally $50 left of me after I
pay my I convinced the lady to not have
me pay my security deposit first and
last I was like you are one room away
from full occupancy in your building you
need to just I promise that I'll be good
for it next month you know I I will give
you the money and then I was not I'll
take you to Vegas and we can play a
little poker that was your first month's
rent as my first month's rent yeah the
$900 that she won yeah in poker had $50
left I was sleeping on the floor I was
stealing my neighbor's Linksys Wi-Fi
without a password on it I was like I
was I set up a little extension cord
from the hallway into my bedroom so that
I can I can keep editing and things like
that and and charge up my camera and
things I went to like soup kitchens and
so you didn't have an electoral Eck
tricity was off it was off and you would
just use the hall outlet yeah for your
lap tied be sitting out there where was
this apartment it was it you know Chris
Thompson yeah yeah he it was his like
apartment building he was he was
upstairs and I was downstairs the
vertical looping around you can see yeah
okay I was walking around that I think
the first time we came we saw you in LA
it was you wish you were in that
apartment still you say oh wow yeah
there was I remember you had electricity
i beliee eventually I got electricity
yeah what was because actually um I got
an offer from two friends of mine to fly
out to North Carolina it was such a
godsend have you know like you guys have
no clue how much that like change in my
life because I I was zero I was down to
like negative
amongst on my bank account and we never
knew this the funny thing is we did at
the time a month i I've inferred some of
it they're like wow you know Joe is he
was broke like in other interviews you
did but even I guess now you're kind of
clarifying something that we didn't did
not know it to this moment oh yeah yeah
I I was really really broke i considered
asking you guys for like my bag check
fee you know i was like now but they're
doing so much already you know well and
let's give our side a story we are
members we were shooting we were in
Coleman Alabama we were shooting the
epic and honest mobile home commercial
which is one of one of my favorites that
we made it's like in the middle of
nowhere Alabama but where we're staying
in Birmingham which is not which is a
nice place I remember we were in this
nice hotel and we were because our spots
are like put us up there yeah and I
remember we were having the conversation
there and we called you we got you on
the phone by that point because we had
decided to do this t-shirt war thing
which we had a t-shirt sponsor on board
and then we came up with the idea
stop-motion t-shirts what we came up
with the idea yeah and once it was a
stop-motion idea I was like this guy Joe
he's like I'd seen everyone had seen
guitar impossible and then the other
stop-motion videos and even this guy
does a lot of stop-motion I just feel
like we should you know he's so
committed to YouTube and he's the
stop-motion guy you know I I just I
think when we conferred about it it
wasn't about well we can also do that it
was like we should work with the YouTube
guy who's the stop-motion guy and it was
a collect it was a an idea for a
collaboration but it wasn't the way
collabs work now which collabs today are
based on just shared audience and
growing your audience yeah it was
legitimately let's collaborate with
someone who's going to bring the
expertise to this idea that we need yeah
no clue how to do stop-motion and also
getting Billy read you know a million
ball right because for the drawings yeah
because we draw anything yeah he was
like what Billy can draw it because we
had done a few
like science channel collaborations with
him or no before that
even before that I can't remember how he
made this was the first collaboration
with Billy too but we knew Billy from my
way back like him and Justin were like
our two revolute Tube friends through
but yeah because it was stop-motion it
was like why try to emulate what you do
when we could call you up so there was
like an email exchange in the first
phone call was we were in Birmingham mmm
I was like man he talks quiet I'm barely
hearing but he's good at stop-motion and
that's what I said - Rhett when we got
the phone and I had no clue you know you
were in LA it was like yeah he's also in
LA this guy's legit man
he's totally committed like he's killing
it I had no clue you were like guys
called me I was literally out like about
to go to like a soup kitchen or
something like that because I was that
broke yeah and I was like a job yes I
was I was so quiet cuz I was trying to
stop all crying cuz there was a all
right I'm trying to replay it cuz I
remember it's like well yeah you'll have
to come out here yeah I was like well
well pay pay pay pay all your expenses
to come out as soon as I said you have
to come out here I'm like oh no I won't
be able to afford that and then you said
immediately then very next thing was
we'll pay you I mean there's a sponsor
involve you know the the t-shirt people
right yeah and I was at cutting and in
this kind of you know it's pretty epic
what ended up happening you guys come
out and we have like basically a couple
of days set aside to shoot this thing
and in that time of trying to right
before Thanksgiving right yeah - we try
to shoot it and we realize that this is
going to be more complicated all the
shirts open to show up that's what
that's what it was yeah yeah yeah yeah
so we then we're like guys I'm sorry we
flew you both out here
and it was like Lillington that basement
studio and we we like did test shots
right before things kind of hung out but
my family was there so you guys were
like paid for my Thanksgiving flight
home because
parents were moving to Clayton North
Carolina right like literally doors
minutes yes what what are the chances
it's so crazy then you guys flew back
there's like I will fly it back around
Christmas I'm like perfect can you fly
back for my birthday too we learned I
mean everybody learned a lot on that but
we learn like you guys you'll have all
the props and you're relying on someone
to ship them to you you know make sure
that timing works don't on that however
I've got a crazy story about that that
you guys I don't think I've told you
guys do you remember how it took me like
an extra like three or four weeks to get
you guys a video it was because my hard
drive crash I was I had long I had to
yeah I had two versions of the footage
right and they were all in these old
like western digital drives and I was
like these these drives are going out
you know I need to make sure that this
is this is good you know and they've
giant giant files so I set up an
automated thing to automatically move
all the files over because one of the my
backup drive had died you know so I was
like okay I'll solve setup step to move
from here to there and instead of moving
it every single file got deleted
literally every single file so I open it
up and it's like it's like that red like
the files are gone kind of thing and I'm
like oh my god it's not like we'll fly
out a third time and do that right it
was like the shirts again yeah it was
like crazy to shoot that it was nuts it
was so meticulous it was one of the most
meticulous thing in I just turned bright
white and I was like how am I gonna tell
these guys that I just lost everything
oh my gosh they spent so much money
flying us out twice like I can't I
messed this up for them I will never
work in this town again this is the end
so that's why the video is you and sup
Ricky our faces over yeah yeah just us
going like oh it's a reverse shot of me
going that's a great video oh my gosh
you see this it's perfect so how did you
you obviously recover the footage and
everybody told us it just took you four
weeks to find know it so I couldn't
afford like I went to some of those like
hard drive recovery places right and
they were like it's gonna be $3,000 and
at this point I'm like that's what no oh
my gosh why so I started researching on
how to do hard drive recovering myself
and I did it I got all the footage there
were like 20 frames that were missing or
no that weren't missing that were like
that had a bunch of weird stuff on the
side so I wrote a scope on that out and
I had to re-edit the entire video again
and that's why it took me I think was
actually like two or three weeks you
edited the video twice twice yeah yeah
yeah I don't remember being like
thinking like oh this is overdue or
anything I don't I mean we had a really
good relationship with that sponsor so I
don't I don't remember ever thinking man
he's taking a long time so you covered
it very well I had a two hellish weeks
trying to recover that footage and like
I had drafted an email that said guys
I'm so sorry like I will pay you back
for this and and like I drafted like a
little payment plan to pay you guys back
well and the funny thing is is that
video ended up doing so much for us oh
yeah I mean yeah they're people who
followed our career for a long time know
that that was a very pivotal moment in
which I would say it was like the first
legitimate viral video you know it was
nice yeah it was the first one it was
just like you search for stop-motion
that was a number one video for like a
year yeah it's kind of what people knew
us for at the time yeah you're the
t-shirt guys that means the song and
yeah yeah yeah yeah the Facebook song
and you had the but yeah this was that
was big this one that exploded more
quickly and I swear we came to LA before
it was finished because I thought we
looked at something or might it might
have been the next one we shot it was a
McDonald's yeah yeah and of course yeah
it for us it for all three of us it led
to the agency for McDonald's and like Oh
Kermie then said they were just gonna
copy us let's yeah we're gonna we're
gonna copy you guys and make a
commercial
but the agency guy said no these guys
are big we should let we should ask them
to do a same thing that you did with me
you know yeah we just asked this guy to
do stop-motion so a lot of
times that was my very first like
national commercial and that was the
first time that I was like I could be a
director hours - yeah it's like cuz we
talked them into we want to shoot it in
North Carolina again we had a bigger
studio and like so better here yeah so
you and Billy came back out we went
through the whole thing we made sure we
had all the t-shirts before we flew you
out huh you probably made sure to back
up the hard drive six hard drive but yes
I mean that was super big and I remember
by the time t-shirt wore what came out
yeah we got a big push from
raywilliamjohnson who we had never met
or talked we had actually met him but we
didn't know we had met it oh yeah I flew
up right after we shot a t-shirt war I
flew up to him because he paid for me to
go there and like help him switch to HD
cuz everything was switching to HD and
he's very like on the button you know so
he was like this guy he does good videos
online a lot of my early stuff was like
you guys you know what he thought which
is like okay this guy knows what he's
doing I'll just I'll just get him let
him do it for me yeah exactly so I'm
doing with the home theater guy right
now so you were right ray william
Johnson's YouTube home theater guy you
went to yeah I went to New York like
same age you can shoot in widescreen you
don't have to like stretch your 4:3 he
was doing some wacky stuff with his web
gift
it was computer we upgraded his his
everything and at that time t-shirt work
came out so he gave us a solid yeah so
he was happy to promote you and we were
along for the ride uh-huh after the big
favor you gave him oh yeah that was a
huge jump to you know when you kind of
roasted us with that video
yeah first time I was publicly called a
hipster III don't you think I knew what
a hipster was then because that was this
until he called me he just made fun of a
lot of ryos yeah he it was the very
first time ever that he was like this
video is so good that I'm having hard
time making fun of it but bear with me
I'm gonna try anyway then I he was like
okay so what are we gonna do here should
I link to you should I link to them I
was like at the time you could hacky
YouTube so that a video would show up on
someone else's main page do you know
what I mean yeah like so I told them
this will be 55
you notice I get a show up on my page
but the video is on their channel so
they'll get the ad money I'll get the
the people checking out my stuff I got I
had no clue and I'm sorry guys you could
have had these I got 80,000 subscribers
in like two days
yeah nuts it was nuts okay I think that
that's fair yeah you didn't tell us
about that but you also didn't tell us
about written but fixing it so that
works out huh
and then I remember when we were
shooting t-shirt war the second time
we're sitting in cup of joe waiting for
Billy to to fly in yeah and you were
like guys I've decided I'm gonna start
making a video every week oh yeah and
I'm gonna I'm gonna do a schedule I said
I'll be every week and I remember
thinking you're crazy yeah you can't do
that I did two videos a week for I think
two days and under the week's start my
channel really started picking up a lot
of steam that started after tisha work
came around the same time you kind of
executed your plan yeah two videos a
week mm-hmm that were like I started
with one video a week and that I swapped
it to two and and you blew up
oh yeah it worked it certainly wasn't
just t-shirt war that was something that
was that was those eighty thousand
subscribers and yeah but yeah but but
yeah you're right I got I got a million
subscribers in something like three
months it was over three or four months
it was and what was that time like I
mean I guess and we didn't have him as a
point of reference we didn't have her
for a while a long time a long time
after that maybe a year or two more but
more than that we didn't get to a
million subscribers until you know
probably 2013 so you just left us in the
door oh yeah and then you guys left me
into this after that but it was you
signed up for something nuts and yeah
you did it for two years yeah what was
that time like did you get did you turn
the power on
you know what turned the power on I
started dating Sarah you know I sleep a
lot though I'm sleeping I mean given the
amount of time that goes into your
videos every single night was up to
three three II 3:30 4 o'clock in the
morning there were a couple videos where
my vlogs like hang uh think goodness for
the glasses you know cuz then my eyes
are just soo
her bag and still to this day where I
was exhausted and there were a couple
videos where I see it in the vlog guys
it's it's 9 o'clock in the morning and
I've been up for 48 hours as soon as I
hit upload on this I'm gonna go sleep
for a really long time and then I would
wake up you know eight hours later and
start reading comments and responding
the comments cuz you can't just put up a
video yeah you need to do it all to the
next one yeah yeah how did you meet
Sarah and when did this happen we there
was YouTube came out with her super
secret Google Nexus phone right and they
flew us all up to San Francisco she was
working for Philip DeFranco at the time
it's like his manager and she you know
we met there at Google you know I didn't
have any people with me you know was
around the same time actually that we
were doing t-shirt war it was so that
December I started talking to her and we
started dating and we were like well
let's never work together we hear about
the horrible things that happen when you
work together right and we were both
agreed 'yeah so then she stops working
for phil and she starts thinking about
hey yeah i think i'm gonna start like
doing this managing thing you know cuz
at the time I had called caaw me all
these agencies and management companies
and they're all like no thinks like
we're not gonna do YouTube you know so I
was like ah there's there's no manager
she's like what about if I do it you
know I'm like yeah I think it'd be great
for you to do with other people yeah so
then it was doing the the McDonald's
thing you know I was like I was flying
there and I prepped myself I had the six
hard drives and I had like the shot list
in my head and I was like I gotta like
do a really good job and then Sony calls
me Sony's like guys I the Joey I saw
your videos we want you to make eleven
videos for us and I'm like that's nuts
no that's that's crazy that's that's 11
videos like because no it's not up on
our channel we want to create like a DVD
that ships with our new Bloggie cameras
that is like a manual you know instead
of having like a PDF or something it
would be like a fun thing like how to
shoot cat videos how to shoot this how
do I shoot fun sports videos you know so
I'm like okay cool so I told told Sara
like listen I know we're not supposed to
be working together but if you could
just take this one thing you know I
can't do this this call and I think I
remember oh she ate oh yeah
just like negotiate and I'm in the
middle of shooting this McDonald saying
I cannot do this I mean this is way more
important you know she's like okay how
much would you break even I was like I
could do to each of you for like a
thousand or two thousand dollars so if
you get it's like twenty or thirty
thousand like that would be that would
be awesome like eleven thousand dollars
you know thirty thousand dollars I mean
I could buy a new camera so she comes
back to me she's like would you begin
with making thirteen videos I'm like
yeah yeah you know for thirty thousand
dollars I still had a thirty thousand
dollars in my mind she goes no like I
think it's time for you to start your
production company I got you one hundred
and ten thousand I'm like oh my gosh so
so literally that that like area in my
life that time in my life I bought like
big turnaround yeah yeah I bought a 4k
camera I start I hired someone for the
first time all that money went really
fast you know cuz I poured it all back
into doing the YouTube videos and I
bought new editing stuff in it like to
this day I still have some of the stuff
from that era even though it was like
five or six years ago you know right
because it you know we bought like
top-of-the-line stuff and and we were
able to make more commercials but she
was your manager so you stopped dating
listen you know we stopped dating and
got married instead and then it wasn't
if she's my manager she's taking 15% he
might as well go into a joint let's
share this chicken so and then shortly
after that I mean in 2011 she turns
around in founds big frame yeah yeah
so she oh she started the clown meeting
before that okay and then you know she
found a partner they switched the name
to big frame and then eventually the
assaulter DreamWorks you know so right
so that was that was huge well like 15
million dollar huge oh yeah something
like she didn't she didn't get 15
million dollar so that yeah company
purchased a company yeah so you know a
lot of the investors got their money
back first well we got a good nice chunk
of change for that which you know made
us be okay with and buying a house here
and yeah in Los Angeles which is not an
easy thing to do right we're all
learning yeah but okay yeah and I want
to talk about that how this lines up
because you know most I've ever talked
about money just so you know like every
single injury that I've ever done like
they said you have any stipulation
and you know if it's a TV thing we're
like don't talk about money but you know
it's like well the sale is a little
acknowledged yeah yeah in terms of like
you know the Sony gig it's like that's
you just we didn't have a point of
reference I think the thing that Sarah
brought was just a power of a point of
reference
exactly it wasn't none of us knew how
much what we were doing was worth oh
yeah nobody knew and everyone was
undervalued thousand dollar everybody
every single person yeah
yeah I mean off it off even after that
t-shirt war once we paid you guys in the
travel stuff we probably made like
$2,000 off the video pirated you know
it's like no one knew what to do yeah
but an in really interesting thing has
happened I mean like that's a major part
of your story too is that you know get
the success that you experienced and
kind of moving and trying different
things yeah but you know YouTube has
changed a whole lot it has you know and
it's interesting when you look at your
videos today you're making videos that
are as high or really higher quality
than you ever made an oh nine and 2010
and 2011 but the audience has changed so
much that a video like your recent video
is like you know the the yarn animation
video that video would have gotten a few
million views definitely three years ago
mm-hmm Rubik's Cube animation how many
Rubik's cubes 100 different Rubik's Cube
1,300 almost you know how many how many
solutions like over a thousand different
item permutation oh so I knew that you
were gonna ask that question I had a guy
call me with all the math I don't know I
mean if you do the math of that on that
video I mean it's in millions for sure
but there's this principle that is
involved in all your videos which is I'm
going to put a bunch of time and effort
and thought and planning and execution
into this thing to create this and half
of the enjoyment of your videos is
appreciating or trying to appreciate
what exactly happened and that's that's
why t-shirt war ended up working when it
did because if you do show it to
somebody and they don't stop and think
they're just like it just washes
but at the moment that you can see in
somebody's eyes when they're watching
that video yeah when they understand
these guys changed t-shirts every single
time over 200 times
yeah when that's how your videos work
there's a month where you get it right
and then you appreciate it and three or
four years ago on YouTube that
translated into an amazing viral
potential yeah why is that not happening
now I don't know I don't know the reason
why I mean one reason of course is
because of volume you know there's a lot
of stuff out there and a lot of really
well produced stuff out there so it's
tougher to like poke through you know of
the the massive amount of people and
crazy amounts of hours that are being
uploaded there's also been a younger
audience coming in which are more
interested in in personalities you know
so the cult of personality so I think
that's another thing too but you know
for me I've you know I've been asked a
lot of times like how do you get big on
YouTube like how do you how do you do it
you know it's like if you're asking that
question it you won't because you're not
doing what you love you know it's and it
sounds so cliche and you know you read
about it in like self-help books and
things like that but it's so true it's
if you're not putting every single
amount of effort that you can into every
single video then at least for me I'm
not getting the enjoyment mm-hm so I
it'll be clear that it I won't be
getting the enjoyment of it some people
are perfectly content with just doing a
daily vlog you know or something like
that and it's fun for them you know I
just don't get that out of it all right
but when but how do you apply how do you
deal with the fact that okay you know an
amazing Rubik's Cube stop-motion video
that would be a 2 million view video is
a 400,000 view video mm-hmm I mean how
how do how do you interact with that
yeah it's just for yourself I'm not
gonna say that it's not like it doesn't
affect me at all yeah of course you know
it'd be like oh man you know I just
think that you know it's like huh if
this would have been 2 million hits the
two or three years ago you know when
there weren't that many people on the
or like when this was brand-new oh well
next it on to the next thing you know so
I would I mean I would still be doing it
literally if I would just post it and it
did didn't even hitch 301 plus you know
I would still be doing it because for me
it's what I get out of it is is making
the actual video you know and if I just
want to just to make money off of it and
you know and if it was a view Zoar or
Fame kind of thing I would have stopped
a long time you know I would have I
would have gone into production you know
by you know just making videos as a
production company you can earn a lot
more money than then you know just doing
YouTube you know trying to like make
youtube videos mm-hmm that's sometimes
you know but your strategy is shifting
well maybe strategy's not a right word
you're my produce your approach is
shifting yeah is is it independent of
performance and is it just because of
where you want to go next and what is
that yeah it's independent perform it's
yeah well I won't say it's independent
completely a performance you know on
videos it's it's it's it made it a good
time of shift because I've always wanted
to get into narrative yeah you need to
make movies to make TV shows to make
stories you know and and to really I've
always been on camera as a necessity
because I didn't have money to pay
actors you know so I've I've always
wanted to direct a movie and now you
know I've slowly been working towards I
started with Meridian which is my first
short film and then a something called
instant getaway and then I was like
let's make an entire reel of move which
is 40 minutes you know so I had 40
minute short film all that were you know
a lot of it was self-funded I were 40
minutes is a what is a reel of real yeah
yeah I haven't heard that meaning it's a
demo v because it's 40 minutes but it's
not a short film because it's not sure
it's technically a short film yeah real
is what they used to use for projections
you know so like you can fit 40 minutes
of a movie into a big reel and then
there's like a little flash on the
screen and then it switches to the next
reel or ones but if you can make a real
you can make a movie it is we had a
third of a movie yeah you know it's a
good practice for me to make a movie and
is it I saw an interesting
at the top of it the question on on that
one was are you building a cohesive
sci-fi universe like between Meridian
instant getaway beyond
yeah yeah well you're like you're on to
us and we being facetious or is it
cohesive yeah it definitely was I mean
this is the same company the same kind
of characters not the same stories but
there's definitely the same company
cipher is the same one you know we are
we have so many things hidden and beyond
that are for the next thing that we're
making you know so I want so there's a
cohesive it all makes sense together
yeah yeah enough where it's it's like a
spin-off almost you know what so what is
the next thing
well the next thing is gonna be a movie
I'm calling a red shift and that's just
a title shift right yeah yeah yeah I
told you about this like I got a lead me
driving a stick shift it's all takes
place it's like that movie with with
what's-his-name minute that all takes
place all in there our Tom Hardy yeah
Tom Hardy is just like that it's just
like luck but it's me in a stick shift
in trying to figure out honey doesn't
know how to drive and I burn the flash
out like the the conflict is I burn the
clutch out and he's gonna push the car
yeah and I push the car and then that's
a preventive explosion a lot of special
oh they called redshifts yeah it's not a
shot in the green screen - yeah we're
very excited about it yeah yeah is it
first time that we're talking about it
okay red shift oh that's what it is like
the Big Bang uh-huh yeah
exactly and we're gonna be shooting up
in Detroit
so we're I think host apocalyptic huh
yes it is yeah mm-hmm Detroit exactly
listen to Detroit and they're like
rolling their eyes of course we get all
the post-apocalyptic movies yeah yeah
yeah I mean there's it's incredible up
there there I've been doing like some
digi scouting is what I call it you know
we've paid a couple photographers to go
out and take pictures but I'm walking
around with Google Streetview
yeah and it's you I didn't know this but
on the top left you can like switch
around there's a little slider that says
historical views so you can go back to
like 2009 2000
seven when they started doing it with
crappier cameras yeah and like you click
on 2009 and you know it's beautiful
neighborhoods and lush lawns and things
like that and then you move on to to
nowadays and it's just like trees
growing through houses and like totally
forgotten in and entire neighborhoods
that are just giant blades of grass
growing and stuff like that it's yeah
it's perfect perfect for the movie that
was so when do you shoot I'm open issue
this year before before winter are you
self funding this too or no this this
one is is a lot more expensive so I'd
have to like sell a couple houses or
something you know if you have a partner
are you getting sponsors or yeah yeah we
have a producer that's attached and now
we're looking for financed ears and we
have to finance ears that are interested
so so yeah well hopefully we'll be able
right now something soon what keep us
posted yeah yeah that's exactly and
thanks for giving us this story and yeah
it was cool to have a part in it you
know why didn't you guys have no clue
how big of a part he had in my life it
was huge I I'm I'm kind of floored by
that you know I I it played a huge part
and you play a huge part in our career
too so it was just it was a confluence
of things so it was a true collaboration
it's certainly not your welcome it's a
WoW
well it wasn't for us to so I think
that's it we just need Billy Reed in
this so you know I know right it would
be like a big reunion all right well we
could wait but I don't already phone
could just find it in a spot deduced an
amazing mystery guitar man signature all
right cool
thanks man thank you
[Music]
and there you have it our ear biscuit
with Joe Penna aka mystery guitar man
let him know how you feel about this
here biscuit or just what you think
about it what you think and feel about
it his Twitter is mystery guitar M
because you couldn't fit mr. guitar man
apparently that's too long mr. guitar M
he were a circuit arm he might could
have fit mystery guitar MA but that's
probably someone else that's his mom let
him know check Twitter hashtag ear
biscuits and remember we appreciate your
reviews on iTunes I feel like the title
at the title the the tables were turned
a little bit in this ear biscuit you
know we were we were surprised by a
number of things and I just want you
know just kind of recap those and hear
your thoughts right one the hard drive
story but to just I I was the fact that
he was appreciative to us for being
instrumental in helping kind of set him
on his career path well we didn't
realize I didn't realize we didn't know
what position he was in at the time that
we asked him to do this we were like
well this guy moved to LA I mean when
YouTube moves you to LA that means you
made it right and that was what we
thought and little did we know that he's
literally taking power from the outlet
in the hallway and in there with nothing
but a computer in his in his apartment I
mean I don't know if we would have done
anything differently it you know if we
hadn't known that but it's just weird
that we had no idea that he was
struggling and that this was like a
really big opportunity we were just like
this guy's great at this we need him in
order to make this video good and this
would be cool to collaborate and you
know so I'm flattered that he wanted to
tell us hey you guys were more
instrumental in my career than even you
even appreciated or knew and like I said
to him that goes both ways you know a
t-shirt war had a tremendous impact on
our career as well I mean there's people
who still come up to us yeah
today it's kind of the trick is the
trademark video for a lot of people and
was for a long time for everybody yeah I
remember
women when we were in LA for something
and then of some kids who were visiting
from Saudi Arabia recognized us and came
up to us do you remember that yeah it
was and it was and they were talking
about t-shirt war and that was just the
first international fans that we ever
met because you didn't I mean even
though those people spoke English you
didn't have to understand English or
have any cultural reference in order to
appreciate that video so yeah thank you
Joe for doing that for us yeah and
certainly there were it his uh his
success rests on you know how great is
working right it's not it's not that we
gave him an opportunity it was just a
collaboration well and thank you for
somehow recovering that footage Oh which
you know I do remember now my memory at
that time because it has been years now
yep my memory that time is pretty foggy
but I do remember there being a little
bit of a delay we worked with a really
you know an easygoing sponsor so they
weren't like demanding that it be done
and I was just like oh this must be
taking a while I remember thinking it
was taking longer than we anticipated
but it wasn't like there was a deadline
so I don't remember getting panicky or
anything but there was a little bit of
asking him about wondering why we're not
seeing anything but he was just like I'm
working on it
and we worked it wasn't working on
recovering that it even exists right and
I mean I'm kind of glad he didn't tell
us what would what what good would it
have done nothing
well I we probably would have paid for
the recovery fee I think that's what
would have a probably definitely glad he
didn't tell us it probably because that
would have been all the profit from the
video go ahead and cover in the yes sure
but it might would have how many years
were knocked off Joe's life in the panic
zone of trying to recover that data that
makes a more epic story I don't want to
that's what you should remember on that
that's what you should remember when
you're going through something difficult
is that maybe this will become an epic
story on a podcast someday all right
does that give you hope your biscuit -
I'm gonna carry that into the next bad
thing that happens to me and you know
what you guys do the same maybe you
don't have a podcast but maybe there's
something that you have you have a story
I like a friend yeah this
for someone who can hear your story or
or not I'm just trying I'm just trying
to help you out or just talk to yourself
a lot of people do that you can talk to
yourself in the mirror to be a good
story to tell myself when this is over
it alright we'll be back here and you
keep talking to yourself it's better to
have a good story than a good time
debate that amongst yourselves we'll
talk at you next week
[Music]
[Music]